the reason i think that cnn is willing
to
play this a little softer now the reason
that cnn is even willing to maybe gently
correct a democratic senator is
not because they've had some wake-up
call not because they
understand that the left is harming the
country
it's because they understand that the
left is losing they're losing
right now and maybe it doesn't seem like
that because the media is putting on a
good show
maybe it doesn't seem like that because
who knows how the presidential election
is going to turn out
but broadly speaking on this argument on
the court argument on the
amy coney barrett argument on the
radicalism argument
the left is losing
here's an important poll we've been
reading some of the polls all the time
here's an important one that doesn't
even mention the phrase
trump or biden but it tells you a lot
and i
i suspect it might have something to do
with the election
gallup asks people are you better off
now than you were four years ago
this was ronald reagan's famous line in
a presidential debate gets up there he
goes well
he's got jimmy carter over here you've
got to ask yourself one simple question
are you better off now than you were
four years ago
right because that's the that's that's
what you have to know if you're
if if you're running against an
incumbent you say you're better off now
than you were four years ago
and the answer is no then you gotta vote
for the alternative and if you are the
incumbent
are you better off now than you were
four years ago
well the answer better be yes the answer
for this incumbent president trump is
yes 56
of people in a survey taken september
14th through the 28th
which obviously is way into the
coronavirus lockdowns right this is not
while the economy was still booming
this is very recently this poll was
taken and still even with the
country shutdown the economy tons of
people out of work
are you better off now than you were
four years ago 56 americans say yes
they are better off they are better off
even in a pandemic
under trump than they were under obama
that's compared to just under a third 32
percent
who say that they are not better off
than they were
four years ago how about on the other
degrees of radicalism obviously we have
blm
burning down the country that doesn't
play very well for the left but even on
some of this these wacky
sexual issues they divide us on race
they divide us on sex
on the sexual issues i don't think this
is playing well in peoria
i'll give you just an example there's a
book review out in the new york times
called
are straight people okay and other
questions about love and sexuality
based on some book castigating marriage
here's just a quick line
in examining the pressure to partner
with the opposite gender we find the
extortions of capitalism the misogyny of
violence against women
the racist and xenophobic erasure of
non-white families
and the homophobic hatreds that pervade
so much of everyday life
this is not outlier in in leftist
discourse this is not an outlier this is
the mainstream this is what you see
broadcast during these crazy rallies
this is even what you see
on presidential debate stages among the
democratic party remember when
julian castro when he was still running
for president he said we need to support
abortion rights
we need to support abortion justice not
just for women
but for trans women meaning men
who put on dresses who i guess can have
abortions now i don't know how that's
possible
this kind of gobbledygook of leftist
jargon
the misogyny of violence against women
racist xenophobic erasure of non-white
family how do you what huh what is that
homophobic hatreds and blah blah blah
it's a
complete complete fictive gobbledygook
and i think a lot of
americans who are not steeped in this
kind of radical ideology look at that
and say huh
i got one guy telling me make america
great again i got one guy
talking to me about the erasure of the
cis trans
non-binary non-white misogynistic
blah blah blah blah blah i think i'm
going to vote for that guy the one who i
can understand you know the one who's
speaking
simple english who says like don't burn
down the country yeah i think that guy
that guy is more persuasive this is how
president trump
who has many personal foibles
was able to win in 2016. this this is
what the media didn't get a lot of the
never trump right never understood this
they thought that president trump won
because he's got this mean personality
he's a real angry
mean cruel guy and he won in spite of
the policy offerings and his kind of
basic view of the country
it was the opposite ann coulter wrote a
great book about this with a very funny
title in trump we trustee pluribus
awesome
but it actually was a pretty pretty
solid book and made a very good argument
which is people voted for trump often
in spite of his personality because of
his policies
because he said make america great again
that's not a trump original he took that
from ronald reagan
but trump has a good ear he has a good
ear for the culture and he realizes that
that idea resonates they voted for trump
might be talking about mika brzezinski's
face and maybe that's
a little distasteful but he hugs the
american flag and he says he's going to
protect manufacturing jobs
other republicans we're not going to
protect manufacturing jobs
he loves the country and he says you
know we all bleed the same blood of
patriots and
we should have no racial division but
also we should have a national border
other republicans were not really saying
that as much
that kind of common sense rings a lot
truer i think if you enjoyed that break
from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss another video